you know I've often wondered why it is  we have children and the conclusion I've  come to is we want someone to get it  right this time  but not me personally speaking I can't  wait to watch life tear you apart India  there's something wrong  yes my father is dead  Richard Stoker was a family man taken  from us by a cruel twist of fate the  reasons for which are unknown India come  and say hello to your uncle Charlie  hello India I'm curious about what  happened to my father  hey Stoker where do you go by stroker  now cuz I hear that's what your mom's  been doing to your uncle  couldn't we talk about your living here  with Charlie like this  it's about happy you know sneaking up on  people following uncle's around  you are supposed to love me for you you  have no idea too cold down there I don't  think so  you won't disappear all the time pack a  small bag what do you want for me to be  friends  we don't need to be friends  we're family